it had been very quiet regarding the
desean watson situation nearly three
weeks since the parties were in court
the lawyers accusing each side of
destroying evidence it had been
cantankerous it felt like it would
continue to be cantankerous instead it
fell
deathly silent in advance to the draft
there was some speculation that a
settlement could be had before the draft
laying the foundation for an in-draft or
maybe post-draft desean watson trade
settlement hasn't happened continued to
be quiet very quiet up until last night
tony busby who represents the 22 women
suing deshaun watson for sexual
misconduct during massage therapy
sessions issued a statement or more
accurately provided quotes on the record
to mark berman of fox 26 in houston and
a couple of takeaways first of all
busby said a settlement is not happening
that's important because that's the
first we've heard yeah from anyone
involved in this regarding whether to
what extent settlement talks are
occurring doesn't mean they haven't
talked though chris what it means to me
is and i firmly believe they have been
talking but they have reached an impasse
on one or more key issues that are
preventing these cases from getting
resolved and sometimes what happens in a
case like this
you find a way
to apply a little pressure to show a
little bit of the sword to do something
to break that log jam and that may be
what busby's calculated effort was in
making the quote that he made last night
to try
to break the ice and get these cases
settled yeah i mean it's it's curious
that we have heard nothing i mean i i of
course i always listen to you in these
type of matters
and
i i would have thought yes that there is
settlement conversations going down here
um but
you know with with with this whole thing
here i mean i don't know how long does
that take to iron out to get a
settlement figured out and all of that
typically mike i mean i would think this
one's going to take a long time with 22
plaintiffs right and everything like
that uh i wasn't expecting an end result
but but i'm i'm i guess i'm surprised to
hear you think this is just more of like
propaganda or playing the playing the
angle of the game here to get what he
wants
i think that there are some global terms
that are holding back
the resolution and that
you got you gotta you gotta get to a
place where everyone's happy on a term
that would apply to all 22. because you
could go in
and you could settle one two this one
this one trim it that's one way to do it
you trim it down to the cases that that
are the ones that are the hardest to
resolve but when you're dealing with one
lawyer who has all 22 of the plaintiffs
and there is
real value in getting all the cases
resolved what's the value to desean
watson in settling three of 22 oh wow
only 19 left right you can chip away
chip away chip away but it still lingers
the cases move forward at some point you
have to testify under oath in a
deposition where tony busby is going to
grill you for eight hours about what you
did what you didn't do and every other
thing about the cases so there's value
in making all 22 come to a conclusion
and my guess is my guess is that there
are one or more global terms that would
apply to all 22 settlements that are
keep it from happen keeping it from
happening that's just my guess and and
yeah i think that
part of this too and this is the other
side of what busby had to say he
expressed concern about the way the nfl
is handling the desean watson what are
you taking away from that
well and let me let me tell you what he
had to say specifically his concern is
that of
four women who met with lisa freel who's
the nfl employee in charge of these
matters some of the women did not feel
like they were being respected that is
buzzby's quote to mark berman and busby
actually said he got involved in the
most recent meeting that occurred the
fourth one
i guess so the client will feel like her
concerns are being more adequately
respected addressed whatever and i don't
know what that means does it mean
they don't think that they're taking it
seriously does it mean that they don't
like the questions they don't like the
tone they don't like the fact that they
feel like they're being accused because
you know sometimes in getting to the
bottom of a situation there's a level of
curiosity right that morphs into a
question that someone could be defensive
about reasonably if you don't have
experience in that system you're
thinking hey i'm telling a story i know
what happened to me what's with all
these questions you make me feel like
you don't believe me so that's possible
too either way either way chris he's
putting public pressure on the league
to do something
to take it more seriously and that puts
pressure in directly onto sean watson
because hey if we don't get these cases
resolved i'm stirring up the nfl's
hornet nest and the hornets aren't going
to fly at me they're going to fly at you
desean because the only way they can
deal with me other than than than saying
you know that i'm the one who's at fault
and they will do some of that but it
puts the nfl on notice that they need to
do everything they can for their own pr
interests
to
create the impression that they are
properly handling these cases which
means a little more aggressively toward
desean watson and maybe move a little
more gingerly when
when talking to the women whose
cooperation the nfl has to have or they
can't do anything they can't force these
people to talk so if these folks aren't
comfortable talking all busby has to say
is that's it we're done no more of these
people are going to cooperate well then
they're not going to get the result they
want from the nfl punishing desean
watson so they gotta they gotta do that
you know listen some of the things i
will not buy the nfl is taking it
seriously come on i'm not that's like
that's not i don't care buzzby does a
great job of putting pressure on the nfl
getting his message out all those type
of things the nfl
has been the opposite ever since the ray
rice issue it's they they care too much
they're too harsh on the players so it's
very hard for me not to believe that the
nfl is not taking this extremely
seriously and yes even within that you
know lisa freer yeah she's trying to get
to the bottom of things here you know
and i'm sure she's done a little you
know
background checks on some of these women
and the accusations and she i'm sure
she's asking some tough questions that
they don't like to like you said to get
to the bottom of this you know that's
where it to me is just a innocent
bystander here i look at it where yeah
if it's your own lawyer the guy you
hired he always asks you you know the
good questions in a good way and makes
you feel good about your case this is
someone trying to get to the bottom of
it they're not you know applying guilt
to either side here so
i mean that's kind of how i took it mike
i don't know where this goes but i would
think that if busby wants what he wants
out of this situation he continues to
let you know his uh clients talk to the
nfl
one of the things that buzzby said in
explaining the
the discomfort that the women were
feeling and talking to the league office
let's be clear he said every time these
women recount this situation they have
to relive it now that's a two-edged
sword because if this litigation goes
forward they will be grilled for eight
hours about everything that happened and
one of the things that
that
a plaintiff sometimes learns the hard
way
and i always tried to explain this to
clients before they would file a lawsuit
and frankly
you know in the conference room as we're
having our initial meeting at some point
i would say
i don't need you to tell me the answer
to this question but you need to answer
this question for yourself
what's the worst thing
you've ever done
you've ever said you've ever been
involved in in any way that you would
not want people to know about what's the
worst thing don't tell me
you don't need to tell me but
you have to assume if you go forward
it's going to come out one way or the
other you're going to have to deal with
it and that becomes an issue chris
whenever someone claims that they have
suffered any type of emotional distress
right mental anguish pain and suffering
lawyers will use that as
an opening of the door to delve into all
the other adversities all the other
traumas all the other stressors that an
individual has experienced because if
this person is damaged
we need to figure out what damaged them
yeah was it this interaction with my
client was it something else right was
it an abusive spouse was it some other
thing that occurred something they did
to create trauma in their lives you
you're opening your life to all sorts of
stuff and
you know these things got filed so
quickly
you just you hope that all 22 of the
individuals realize what they're getting
realize what they've signed up for
because it's more than just reliving
that trauma it will eventually be one
questioned by rusty hardin and his
associates reliving pretty much every
trauma you've ever experienced in your
life and every negative impact
from the interaction with desean watson
and and they already knew it it's not
like buzzby's saying that changes
anything they were still going to do it
but this confirms that that yeah this
litigation process and lawyers do it all
the time defense lawyers do it all the
time it's in the playbook if there is
one
you you make the experience
as legitimately unpleasant as possible
under the guise of i'm just doing my job
that's how it works that's how the game
is played yeah i mean listen i'm not
surprised to hear that
you know and again too these are serious
accusations so i i can't fault the
defense for having serious really tough
questions here you know yeah they gotta
see i mean we
you know and again i'm not trying to say
anything but we've seen plenty of cases
where we know people in these situations
do lie and things like that i've seen it
both ways in the nfl hey and i'm not
regardless but chris yes yeah they've
already said rusty harden has already
said we believe they are lying right so
so does that mean
that when it's time to question them
face to face under oath they're gonna
operate with kid gloves or does that
mean they're throwing the gloves down
and it's time to start swinging right
right they're coming after these people
this is going to be and this is going to
be the most unpleasant experience of
their lives when they're grilled by
rusty harden because he's already said i
think you're lying yeah no i i mean yes
that that's that's part of the pain they
have to relive and then you know i know
that's not easy if this was true it was
tough for these women and all those type
of things i know that's not an easy
situation definitely not but uh yeah
it's it's within the rights of harden
and watson to cross-examine and do those
type of things to protect watson who's
who's hardens clients so we'll see where
it goes i mean again mike like okay so
here we are i'm gonna ask you
pasta meatballs all right what's what's
anything new in the gut do you think
this is gonna get resolved before the
season's over
you got any info that you hear out there
where you you feel like you got a lien
either way
i think that what busby's doing here is
trying to apply some extra pressure to
rusty harden and deshaun watson to get
whatever it is
that is holding up a settlement whatever
that issue is
whatever the issue is one or more issues
whatever it is he's trying to get it
resolved i i think that that that this
is his way of stirring the pot just
enough to nudge it toward resolution my
gut continues to be that these cases get
settled before training camp but you
know
i i i wouldn't wager money on that in
large part because i wouldn't wager
money on anything because i am
extremely cheap but i i i just believe
if i had to pick one of the other
settled or not sell it before training
camp i think these cases are going to
get settled before training camp
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports